mein thema heute ist einst das mich
tatsächlich erschreckt hat denn es gibt
einen es gibt uns einen ausblick darauf
was uns denn erwartet und drohen würde
wenn laschet und lindner nicht noch
aufholen können denn 75 prozent der
unternehmer in deutschland würden ihre
investition in deutschland zurückstellen
wenn tatsächlich rot-rot-grün kommt und
der umfrage zufolge auch über 94 prozent
der familienunternehmen befürchten dass
der wettbewerbsvorteil in deutschland
und auch das image von deutschland
massiv beschädigt würde und deutschland
wählt sich somit gerade mit diesen drei
parteien eine riesige gefahr für
investitionen arbeitsplätze zusammen
denn wenn die unternehmen nicht mehr
genug geld haben nicht mehr genug geld
investieren können dann verlieren sie an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und im ersten
schritt gehe natürlich die löhne runter
und gefährden dann auch noch
arbeitsplätze und das steht ja sogar
alles schwarz auf weiß in diesen drei
wahlprogramme von spd linken und grünen
eine höhere steuerbelastung mehr verbote
mehr vorschriften in welche technologien
wir als unternehmen in zukunft
investieren sollen noch unflexibel
arbeitsgesetze und ja wer
immobilienkonzerne enteignen will da ist
die enten oder staatliche eingriffe in
produktionsbetrieben nicht mehr weit
entfernt und fakt ist die wahlprogramme
von spd linken und grünen gemeinsam
haben sie eins gleich sie würden die
kosten der demografischen entwicklung in
deutschland völlig ausblenden stichwort
rente und beamtenpensionen ihre
wahlversprechen häufen damit häufen sie
enorme neue schulden an und das würde
natürlich die wirtschaft massiv
schädigen und deswegen sollten scholz
und bernburg meiner ansicht nach jetzt
noch vor der wahl politische klarheit
schaffen und ein bündnis mit der
wirtschaftsfeindlichen linken
ausschließen und gleichzeitig sollte
aber auch die cdu und die fdp versuchen
ihre stammwählerschaft zu mobilisieren
und insbesondere auch die cdu sollte
definiert hier definitiv noch luft nach
oben also da wünsche ich mir ein
bisschen mehr dynamik
ja ich meine ich verfolge mit wachsender
fassungslosigkeit das was da möglich zu
sein scheint und ich kann das etwas aus
der schweiz beurteilen da kommen viele
deutsche unternehmer ich spüre dass auch
immobilienmarkt da gibt es also viele
leute jetzt wohlhabende kreise
mittelständler leute die arbeitsplätze
schaffen die unternehmen führen die also
das geld die wissen wie man einen
bleistift verkauft im unterschied zu den
meisten deutschen politikern im
unterschied zu den meisten politikern
die keine ahnung von marktwirtschaft
haben und die überlegen sich jetzt also
immobilien zu kaufen in der schweiz
haben angst vor dieser perspektive die
halten also für möglich dass
rot-rot-grün kommt und ich beruhige dann
die uns aber viel schlimmer als jetzt
ist auch rot rot grün nicht weil die
sind ja jetzt schon so weit links
draußen und ich muss euch meine die
grünen das ist ja eigentlich das schöne
und diesem wahlkampf da werden ja die
dinge plötzlich zur kenntlichkeit
entstellt
jetzt sagt auch diese annalena baerbock
in diesem dreikampf der jedes verbot ist
ein wartungsfrei und als wir verbieten
und alles wir verbietet alles dann haben
wir die volle innovation und wenn du
eine grüne politikerin aus die so denkt
dann brauchst du die die die linkspartei
gar nicht mehr weil dann hast du sie
schon in den grünen und ich sage die
grünen sind eine mogelpackung die sind
nur außen grün ich bin auch ein grün
aber ich bin nach hin wenn die grünen
die grünen die sind nur ausgefüllten
innen sind die noch dunkel rot raus die
linkspartei also während irgendwas beten
dass die cdu das armin laschet von
diesem kinde wahlkampf irgendwo wieder
den politikerin sich entdeckt und eine
vernünftige cdu her ins ziel führt weil
sonst muss ich sagen die
immobilienpreise in der schweiz die
werden so nach oben schießt weil so
viele deutsche und auch herr gottschalk
da wird sich am schluss sein haus in der
schweiz kaufen was ich natürlich super
wenn der abwehr deutschland braucht auch
noch ein paar gute leute ich hab ja ich
war ja schon mal nah dran also da hat
george harrison hat sein haus verkauft
und dann dachte ich dass ich
meinen stuhl aufgekauft
also sind ja seine frau wollte ihr haus
loswerden und dann hab ich ihm im wahn
bin ich da hin geflogen das war dann
wirst du sie also große komiker schon
sagen aber dass man man man sagen viel
vom see und das war das war dann nicht
so wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe aber
ich war drauf und dran und dann hab ich
irgendwo in anschlusskäufen dann gab es
in der nähe von zürich ein schloss
teufeln da habe ich dann gedacht das ist
es und dann hat mich der jungs natürlich
nicht leisten da braucht seinen coach
auch in schlosswil hat man sich aber
damals dieter schumanns minister zur
ordnung gerufen ich musste unter
schröder bei eichel einmarschieren der
sein sparschwein da stehen also das
können sie nicht machen das ist okay
dann las ich also hans eichel
persönlicher hans eichel hat mir gesagt
wenn sie in die schweiz gehen bin ich
von ihnen schwer enttäuscht und gucken
wir werden das ist aber der einzige der
darauf glaube ich gehört hat also alle
anderen prominenten dazu aber jeden um
leben zu sagen aber das sensationell
dann nimmt einer sein amt und seine
aufgabe passiert absolute dass da
kümmere ich mich jetzt selber darum dass
der gottschalk sozusagen weiter so
steuern eingetrieben hätte beiden
großartig wäre jetzt 100 dass die
geschichte die geschichte ist stand noch
nicht im bild aber was ist die drei
gesetzt hat
das ist die tragik der deutschen politik
dass diese politikern eine politik
machen die diese firmen vertreibt die
leute weg hat die eigentlichen über den
deutschen und bleiben würden aber
anstatt sich zu hintersinn und das haben
sie gedacht hätte warum geht ein
geschenk warum gehen die weg oder heute
wenn die politiker warum verlassen
eigentlich der auf kaufkräftige leute
unternehmen tolle leute mit gestellt das
land sagen sie das ist das ist einfach
ein vaterlandslose gesellen das ist ihn
endlich deine frau wird zumindest avant
gewesen zu sein wenn er wenn der thomas
gottschalk überzeugen musste ich doch
überlegen was ich für eine politik
machen muss dass die leute hier bleiben
und hier kommen und darum müsste man
eigentlich sie in die deutsche regierung
hinein bringen vor allem wenn wir uns
überlegen dass wir in deutschland die
besonderheit haben des deutschen
mittelstandes und familien und generator
familie unternehmen die über
generationen hinweg schon bestehen und
natürlich wollen wir als
familienunternehmen hier bleiben ja
unser familienunternehmen ist knapp 100
jahre alt wir denken gar nicht erst
daran ins ausland abzuwandern aber
gerade mit solchen substanz steuern
wieder vermögen der der vermögensabgabe
geben gibt es immer mehr unternehmer die
sagen ich kann hier in zukunft nicht
mehr wirtschaften ich bin nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig kann die löhne nicht
mehr zahlen die arbeitsplätze nicht
halten wenn so eine regierung kommt aber
wäre das natürlich erschreckend aber
wenn durch die hälfte der wähler
das haben will dann muss man als
demokrat doch sagen dann ist das jetzt
eben mal für eine zeit so also bei 25
und 17 und 8 ungefähr so das wird
reichen und dann muss olaf scholz sogar
rot rot grün machen weil er nämlich
sonst die mehrheit derer die ihn gewählt
haben und die dieses bündnis für gut
halten enttäuscht am wahlabend also das
ist ja die eigene gefahr ja absolut aber
genau das fehlt mir momentan deswegen
spreche ich das auch so klar an was es
für folgen haben wird weil dass ich als
junge unternehmerin als junge familie
unternehmerinnen gar keine perspektive
mehr in deutschland haben ist das nicht
immer schwieriger wird und ich spreche
hier im namen von über 6000 familien
unternehmer und junge unternehmer und da
müssen wir doch etwas tun das heißt die
leute lesen sich leide die wahlprogramme
nicht mehr durch und wir sind klar
ansprechen aber dass die wahlprogramme
eigentlich gar nicht durchlesen für mich
ist auf der erste satz jedes verboten
ist ein innovationstreiber da muss ich
doch sorgt sein sei aber das haben mir
lesen ist ja um die komplette
geisteshaltung einer person und einer
politik zu kennen aber doktorarbeit aber
jetzt mache ich das doch was macht also
das ist ja auch sagen wir so niklaus der
satz ist doch in sich auch wenn ich
verbietet verbrenner motoren zuzulassen
dann ist es im innovations- boost für
alternative antriebe wenn ich es nicht
für bietet dann ist es in innovation
pusten also ganz aber wohl an der ksv
davon weil irgendwer die wählscheibe
verboten hat der mensch strebt doch von
sich aus zur innovation es gibt doch
auch ohne grüne verbote menschen die
gerne tolle dinge erfinden zu glauben es
braucht annalena baerbock die die
wählscheibe verbietet damit steve jobs
das iphone findet ist doch einfach da
also borderline totalitäres denken also
es ist natürlich wie im weil wir wir
fordern immer dass politiker im
wahlkampf zuspitzen dass sie die
debatten auslösen jetzt sagt die frau
einmal verbote sind innovationstreiber
und spitz damit einen gedankengang der
nicht ganz falsch ist so und schon
wieder falsch
ich bin hier vorbei der gedanke ist eben
ganz falsch aber er ist wunderbar dass
er formuliert wird weil man weiß was die
leute denken was ist ein
innovationstreiber ein
innovationstreiber ist wenn man auf die
eigenverantwortung der unternehmer und
ihre innovationskraft vertraut wenn der
staat die innovations- steuern würde wie
das frau brooke sich vorstellt wenn die
staaten autos bauen das haben wir ja
gesehen das hat ja länder gegeben zum
beispiel die sowjetunion und die ddr die
haben ja führende autos gebaut ich werde
ihn traurigen oder wenn die wenn die
staaten computer bauen würden dann
werden die computer noch so groß wie
turnhallen nein hier da kommt ein
komplett falsches denken zum ausdruck
und ich bin entsetzt dass sich hier eine
art blockierung des claus strunz in
dieser
frage mich was ist mit claus strunz
passiert
taktische oder was war da im spiel klar
das ist ja alles schön wir bauen denn
was ich habe einmal gesagt dass ich die
grünen wichtig finde als sozusagen
impulsgeber und auch diese zuspitzung
und übertreibung als die ich sehe er
sagt er da kommt das ist die hässliche
fratze zum vorschein
ich sage das ist eine ganz kluge frau ja
mit einer halle gegen die grüne idee ist
ja von allen die sich für schlau
erhielten als der rest der welt wozu wir
alle gehören ist ja gepflegt worden aber
als die grünen plötzlich den wahrheit'
test antreten mussten hat man gemerkt
dass zwischen idee und ideologien thomas
und ich finde dass jetzt wird ihnen
wahrscheinlich ganz übel werden aber ich
finde dass mittlerweile die den
wahrheit' test gar nicht mehr so
abschreckend dann kommt ja doch mal mit
rot-rot-grün vier jahre lang der
wahrheit' test und ich habe immer mal
dann sehen wir mal ob sozusagen alles
was ihr sagt also diese ganzen
teufelinnen die an die wand malt ob das
wirklich so ist wenn es länder der
teufel oder nein ich dachte oder konkret
auf annalena baerbock heute bei den
teufel der häufig männlichen lehrern
oder heute darf männlich bleiben
ja aber die beiden öffentlich
rechtlichen sind die aussteller mussten
inzwischen länder also es ist auch nicht
ob es jetzt einmal zu sagen und dir
wieder frieden also es ist jetzt auch
nicht meine lieblingsposition aber dabei
ich finde sie ist auch nicht ganz so
schlecht wie sie geredet und einen
gedanken da bin ich da bin ich bei dir
ich meine das ist zwar ein
menschen experiment mit offenem ausgang
wenn man den deutschen da eine rot rot
grüne regierung wünscht aber in der
opposition könnte natürlich auch eine
cdu ja wieder an profil gewinnen und an
diese mehltau der mercury langsam wieder
herausfinden zu dem was eigentlich eine
cdu sein müsste aber ich möchte es den
deutschen nicht zumuten als ich das
nämlich mal in dieser sendung gesagt
gesagt habe die müssen in die opposition
ob ich einen derartigen shitstorm
geerntet von deutschen die gesagt haben
das ist verantwortungslos wenn sie
deutschland eine rot rot grüne regierung
zumuten wollen
darf das nicht sagt ist nur ein name zum
abschluss dieses debatten teils wer wäre
für die union oder für die cdu der
perfekte oppositionsführer wasserkuppe
oppositionsführer oppositionsführer ich
rede lieber nein für mich ist armin
laschet die perfekte verkörperung des
deutschen bieten meyer und der
biedermeier wird unterschätzt
wir haben ja in der opposition finde ich
ganz ganz apart wieder meine ob da
gehört dahin sana er wäre der beste
oppositionsführer für die cdu wenn es so
käme also ich denke laschet wird es gut
machen
könnte ich mir gut vorstellen
klaus merz oder ein jüngerer märz thomas
aber ich gerade gesagt na
ja also der biedermeier das ja bitte
[Musik]